كشفت صحيفه
البريطانيه ان الممثله الامريكيه عنبر
هيرد تركت هوليود وانتقلت للعيش في
العاصمه الاسبانيه مدريد
امبير مشاهدينا قررت الابتعاد عن الجدل
بعد خسارتها قضيتها الشهيره التي رفعها
ضدها طليقها النجم جوني ديب قبل نحو عام
صحيفه طبعا هذه الصحيفه ذكرت ان الممثله
الامريكيه انتقلت لاسبانيا مع ابنتها
اوناها تتحدث الاسبانيه بطلاقه ويقولون هي
سعيده على كل حال يعاد
منزلها في ولايه كاليفورنيا مقابل 1.1
مليون دولار في عام 2022 يعني حاسه انه
يعني سعره رخيص نوعا ما بالنسبه
لكاليفورنيا والله ولجات ايضا مشاهدينا
الى اسبانيا بعد عام على القضيه الشهيره
وايدت المحكمه جوني ديب لتحكم لصالحه
بمبلغ 15 مليون دولار
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات